[Music]
[Music]
how's it going very good
i'm wearing i mean i do often wear my uh
headphones only on one ear but i'm
specifically wearing my headphones on
one air today because
got a little bit of hearing have you
really just a tiny bit of air right last
night what do you think's caused that i
don't know but i did have a um
is it called a fever dream last night
you know where i don't know if my
temperature is up but you know when you
dream is quite vivid and strange this is
a weird one right
kissing cuddling a girl right i think it
was yunjin kim
who played son in lost oh right okay a
lovely korean couple i think i was
kissing her quite passionately last
night with your lips with my lips
but
her tongue was only slightly held on by
the finest kind of bit of sinewy gristle
so every so often her tongue would fall
into my mouth because she was on top of
me and i go oh you're okay here you go
like just flip it back into her and then
we'd kiss again and then again it would
just go
fall into my mouth like a slug or
something
and then i woke up this morning had a
little bit of earrings so i don't know
what that's about suppose what do you
think that dream means i don't know i
mean yunjin is a wonderful woman very
very lovely ladybug and as far as you
know her tongue is completely attached
yes intact but i've never i've never
held any you know long seated you know
love secret love for her well dom um you
know you got me a book about the human
body got you a few books but go on but
i've started reading one of them
brilliant have you read the body one i'm
starting to read it and i'm at the bet
where it looks at the brain which is in
your body at the top there brilliant the
only part of the body that named itself
there you go there you go
well they were talking about a part of
the brain i've forgotten the name of it
but it's said in deep dom
cindy okay maybe in the weight matter
you're right and it's just a tiny little
thing and it deals with fear
and uh it's a tiny amygdala it might be
i think it might
be but they said that it gets very
active at night when you dream right
that's why there can be a lot of fear in
a dream even if it's not a scary thing
right yeah so maybe you were kissing but
oh i'm scared your tongue's gonna fall
off
uh so maybe that's what was happening
because that fires up at night and uh
and there's people who have been in
accidents where that's been you know
destroyed or hurt and they have no fear
of anything no fear i've got a friend
how would you like a life like that
would that be good or bad a friend who
pretty much has no fear
base jumper wing suit uh works with very
dangerous animals drives very fast
motorbikes
he really has no fear do you think
there's something wrong with him
i think his amygdala
excuse me red bull and his uh adrenal
system is a little off but that's
interesting that you said fear because
obviously when our brain has a chance to
rest maybe it goes to the places that it
wants to try and make sense of and a lot
of times we're making sense of our fears
our insecurities our anxiety so it all
passes through this little bit and it
kind of gets rid of it gets rid of that
stress dom is that the part of the brain
that they argue was the first to be
formed in
us is that the idea it's the rudimentary
brain i don't know and then the bit
grows around it but does it if anyone
out there would like to come on the
friendship onion who is an expert in
brains and how they were that would be
an amazing guest that would be a great
guest or even if you're an actor and you
play one on tv like say for instance
grey's anatomy yeah then we'll we'll
speak to you about it and see
do you actually learn anything when
you're on those shows or the guy from
house on exactly and the book is called
just to give a shout out is
bill bryson is bill bryson who's
fantastic all those books are great and
the book is called the body i think it's
called the body i knew you'd like it oh
it's very good already i've just started
it i'm only you know i know we're into
it
my favorite part was the digestive
system i thought that was absolutely
fascinating well it's incredible what
happens
and your digestive system
tom
i'm i'm also reading brian greene's new
book right who we've had on as a guest
and fantastic guest but we won't get too
deep into this just now but maybe brian
green could come back on now that i've
read this new book yeah if he'd like to
because
i've learned a lot of new stuff but if
you take digestion all the way down to
physics
it's basically just
molecules passing electrons to each
other right
that is what life is right the whole
thing everything energy was that energy
passing energy backwards and forwards
basically well it's not even that but
passing electrons back and forward
creates energy
so ultimately
all life
you playing soccer
you on the rift playing league of
legends
kissing people in a dream with floppy
tongues it's basically just molecules
passing electrons to each other
we should have brian greene back on he
was an amazing guest and there's so much
more to learn from him yeah let me
finish this book first yeah and then
we'll go on to johnny clues and he can
get on the phone to brian and see if he
wants to come back on well we should
crack on because we do have another
guest today but we do want to do a
little bit of housekeeping from the last
few episodes that we've had and we we
thought we were going to call it
peeling the onion i like that done yeah
peeling the onion peeling the onion
because sometimes questions come up like
the brain one there or other questions
and then we forget
and and i i'd like to take a moment here
john take a moment take three i would
like to take a moment to say thank you
to our fantastic listeners and watchers
yes because i've i've i've spent a lot
of this week actually looking at
people's um comments and answers and and
people doing pieces of art for the
friendship onion
and and writing stuff and poems and and
it's brilliant see the people that are
interested in this show i like them a
lot tom yeah we have a very dedicated
group of people who are interested in
the french bunion and we do appreciate
all of your
uh care and concern because you're the
reason why we make it you know but keep
telling your friends we haven't said
this for a while dom
we haven't said it for such a long time
i forget what it is you've got to
subscribe
rate and review that is very important
why i'm not sure dom but we want to grow
the audience and uh
looking at it all this week i get very
excited about the show dom i think
subscribing is obviously just that means
that it shows up in your phone without
you needing to go search for it and we
have an extra follower rating and
reviewing yeah especially if you give us
a good review and a good rating means
that we go up to the top of people's
kind of watching
chance so instead of them getting the
chance to watch something that most
people think is rubbish they get a
chance to think to watch something that
most people think is good which if you
rate and review as highly would be tfo
the friendship
so let's get peeling the onions um
with some questions that we've been
asking uh the last couple of weeks and
things that we need answers to william
over the last few weeks of doing the
podcast i had mentioned to you that the
lord of the rings trilogy in the united
states has a pg-13 rating which means
that in each of the films you could put
in a swear word and it would get past
the senses we asked
where you would put that swear word and
we do have a few correspondence so you
start with that one and i'm gonna find
some stuff on my instagram and there is
there is on you're only allowed one
you can't just you can't just be
throwing a lot of swear words in uh
but um
yeah you could only have one
um so let's have a look at some people
so we've got green dragon reprised
who sent in this one for a return of the
king
gimli
the dwarf to legolas the elf
that still only counts as [ __ ] one
see
that's a good one
have you found one nailed it i've got
one here on my instagram
uh from jamiesmart93 what's happening
jamie smart who says i'll do my best to
aim at kellen impression here a wizard
is never linked through the baggage nor
is he earlier he arrives precisely when
he
means to
not that not bad
i took i took a photo of a few because i
like them and you know how i like i like
tree beard ones for something
so uh a tree beard
side i am on nobody's side because
nobody is on my
side little lock
that's nice love it
this one from roz linen i actually think
this works pretty well and you know you
could have put it in there earwind in
return of the king i am no
man now that actually works quite well
that actually works as a you know i mean
you put that in and you think yeah fair
enough hey i forgot to say it was josh
curtis who did the three beard one and
i'm gonna
i'm to do this is my last one okay
because i like this great red spot
said uh a galadriel quote oh yes in
place of a dark lord
you would have a queen
that's a good one all right i'll end
with this one because you know how much
i love bipping in those movies this from
frank.saber
pippin in fellowship of the ring all
right where are we going
sending more of your suggestions we love
those things is there anything else that
harks back over a few episodes that we
want to be yeah i did i did
i found a great one here john
uh laura wistenre what a lovely name
laura wistenra gave us a good answer to
a question that i had in fact i had a
half of an answer and not even half of
an answer i had 20
of an answer okay to a question that you
had yeah why do you put eggs in the
fridge in the fridge okay let's hear it
and i said to you well you don't in
britain yeah in america and i said i
didn't really i don't know but anyway
laura with sten russ says
you only have to refrigerate eggs if you
wash them
there's a kind of natural protective
coating on eggs that comes off after you
wash them in america the farming
practices are usually more unsanitary
unsafe so it's required if you get eggs
from your own chickens and they're not
covered in muck you can leave them
unwashed
unrefrigerated right that makes sense
now when she's talking about the natural
protective coating she mean the shell i
know on the shell there's a sort of
well i call it an emotional brilliant
word brilliant brilliant there's an
emotion and in the uh certainly in
factory farming of eggs there that gets
washed and and knocked off in america so
it's all ready you need to refrigerate
it as soon as you buy it yeah and also
don't buy battery farms
i buy all my eggs
from places where the eggs get a chance
the eggs the chickens get a chance to
run out imagine the eggs were all
running around crazy but you you can see
on each on any box it will say
these chickens you know walk around on
the ground
with the sunshine and they get a chance
to forage naturally those are the eggs
you want battery farmed eggs no yeah and
you have to watch the wording dom
because they can use words that makes it
sound like it's better than it is
so good
again 20 of this i've read
but there's words like
uh free roaming
means may not mean that means they've
got a bit more space in their cage so
what i do and this is probably the wrong
thing to do but i i go for the one
that's got the most so it's if it says
organic
cage-free antibiotics
yeah then you're like okay that's got a
lot of stuff going on this has got to be
good people if there's anyone out there
that's an expert in eggs yeah chickens
tell us if you're going to eat eggs
where is the best place rather other
than go having your own chickens number
one going to a farm number two yeah if
you're going to a supermarket what is
the best way to know that you're buying
good eggs where the chickens are treated
well if you could let us know we will
peel the onion on that i would have my
own chickens absolutely in los angeles
but
there are wild coyotes in this part of
the world and i love those animals
they're fantastic but absolutely the
coyotes would eat the chickens within a
couple of days so there's no point and
the next best thing like you said is a
farm that you know yeah someone said
it's a gift
this came from someone graves
uh in
captainsville
mid
mid
mmdd is he a doctor massachusetts no it
can't be massachusetts john
m d state
maryland maryland
i'm sorry to do this to you but do it
maryland mary
as you know california new york
florida i'm going to say the very last
digit of your index finger so index over
here they'll go out or that way yeah
right there so down the bottom yeah
on it
kind of between california and florida
um i don't know
johnny johnny clues ireland no you're
way off now
towards new york
past new york oh my gosh i will ah if
you go past new york you're in the water
well new york's a wide state oh new york
is a wide state
state well anyway great north of
washington dc north of washington
thank you is that a tiny is it one of
those tiny states
it's like a medium
i would say medium small it's a medium
smoothie we say maryland in britain
maryland they they go merlin merlin
anyway graves has sent us what appears
to be like some sort of
breakfast cereal
that's fantastic how many is there
there's there's more haven't that look
at all
chili crunch
momo
fuku chili that looks hot that is just
chili oil that is hot let me tell you
if you stick your index finger in that
just know
sure i read this yeah
it's from katie graves not graves katy
graves says to us so says dearly dom i
wanted to suggest chili crunch for when
you eat the world it's delicious on
ramen fried rice noodles i also love it
on mashed potatoes and even with a
cracker a little goat's cheese and a
tiny bit of chili crunch i hope you
enjoy i'm a huge tolkien fan and i have
been really enjoying your podcast your
easy camaraderie is a joy during these
challenging times oh katie that's very
sweet and she said be well from katie
graves in maryland this
might be a little bit of a uh
competition against uh jardiner but you
and i both love hot food so we should
have a look at that yeah look how hot it
looks look at the oil on top easy chili
oil but is this is this a certain thing
from thanks katie
please send it if you've got any
suggestions or gifts that you want to
send us or anything at all you can get
in touch with us
at um
oh the friendship on your
netcastmedia.com that's cass with a k or
you can send us a message at speak pipe
forward slash the friendship on you no
i've done it wrong speakpipe.com
that's who makes it wow that looks
fantastic maybe we could do that next
week what do you think john john says
yes do you have ambitious hiring goals
no sweat because you're not waiting for
the right candidates to find you you're
finding them first with indeed if you're
hiring you need indeed because indeed is
the hiring partner where you can attract
interview and hire all in one place and
indeed is the only job site where you're
guaranteed to find quality applications
that meet your must-have requirement or
else
you do not pay instead of spending hours
on multiple job sites hoping to find
candidates with the right skills you
need one powerful hiring partner that
can help you do it all with instant
match as soon as you sponsor a post you
get a short list of quality candidates
with resumes on indeed that match your
job description and you can invite them
to apply right away plus you only pay
for quality applications that meet your
must-have requirements one of the things
i love about indeed is it makes it easy
to hire great talent according to
comscore indeed is the number one job
site worldwide
start hiring right now with a 75
sponsored job credit to upgrade your job
at indeed.com onion offer valid through
march 31st go to
indeed.com to claim your 75 credit
before march 31st indeed.com onion terms
and conditions apply need to hire you
need indeed
when i work out and even when i don't i
like to dress comfortably that's why i
was so excited when i found fiore they
offer premium performance apparel
inspired by the active coastal
california lifestyle you're right dom i
love the ore you know that oh yeah and
it's all made to work out and but it's
so comfortable i'll wear them all the
time fiori is the most comfortable
clothes you will ever buy the clothing
is incredibly versatile it can be used
for just about any activity you like
like running training swimming even yoga
but also great for lounging or weekend
errands like billy said and it's super
easy to find the product online you're
looking for at their website the ori is
a hundred percent offset in their carbon
footprint by utilizing better
sustainable materials for their products
empowering your best active lifestyle
feel good about the things you buy and
also how they are made my latest
favorite from them is the sunday
performance jogger i love them dom i
wear them all the time around the house
but also out and about viori is an
investment in your happiness for our
listeners they are offering 20 off your
first purchase get yourself some of the
most comfortable and versatile clothing
on the planet at viori.com
onion that's
v-u-o-r-i dot com slash onion not only
will you receive 20 off your first
purchase but enjoy free shipping on any
u.s orders over 75 dollars and free
returns go to viori.com onion and
discover the versatility of the iori
clothing well i might be seeing you this
weekend coming down for a little bit of
uh
ufc and maybe a little bit of ufc uh
computer game playing and maybe
either watching a christmas story which
billy has never seen anyone in the
united states or
a clockwork orange which you've never
seen either i've never seen that one of
those so maybe you take it what's a
classic film you've never seen there's a
lot i've not seen going with the wind ah
citizen keem
uh oh no i love citizen cake i haven't
seen it i love it what was the film that
i recently watched that i thought was
very citizen kane-esque
the muppets in new york yeah no i've
forgotten we've got to guess we're gonna
have to move on is that come on is that
it for our correspondence
and we have peeled the onion for this
week
now who is a fantastic guest this right
where do you see this guy tom wait till
you see this guy
daniel
welcome
to the friendship onion daniel i'm going
to have a go at your second name here
daniel
hassenbos
that's very close yes how how would it
be pronounced
uh a hasson boss
boss of course and that is does that
have a direct translation in dutch is
that like the man who eats haribo or
something like that no that is uh that
means hair wood
hair would
that's strange it'd be good if it was
map drawer yes map maker because that
would make sense because daniel you are
one of the great map makers in all the
land
absolutely daniel
we're going to read a little blurb about
you here
um that says daniel's a freelance
fantasy cartographer map maker
now captography netherlands who made
who's made maps for several role-playing
gay books as well as fantasy novels for
the past
two years he's been building a fictional
world map by map that he uses in his own
donderson dragons campaign and shares on
his patreon so other people can use the
maps as well so you're making
your own personal map for your own
personal dungeons and dragons campaign
but then people can take that map and
use it for theirs too is that right
daniel
yeah that's correct and it's not just
one map it's a whole set of
interconnected maps of different
villages and towns and kingdoms wow now
do you have you printed that out or is
it all in a computer program thing
uh well most of it is in the computer
uh i do all my art digitally but you can
see part of one of my maps hanging
behind me so that's uh
that's not a map of the world that's a
fictional map of somewhere that doesn't
necessarily exist apart from in your
mind yeah yeah exactly fantastic and um
we we thought it would be super
interesting to talk to you uh for many
reasons really but for our quirky
working segment uh which this is dom
yeah it is and uh we
first off
how would people get to see your maps
before i start asking you questions on
it so it's on your patreon
so uh we'll we'll put it on the screen
here yeah somewhere we will so that
people can get access to your maps
yeah yeah that would be great yeah it's
my patreon and uh everywhere you can
find me as daniel's maps so pretty
straight
forward i'm writing this down now
daniel's maps i've had a look online and
they are fantastic i absolutely love it
i've always been intrigued by maps and i
know that you're
the reason you got interested in it is
through tolkien correct
yes yes that's correct yes because i
read i don't know if this is true and
you might know this daniel but i read
um
tolkien
drew the maps of middle earth before he
wrote the story
so it came from the languages and the
maps and that's where all this kind of
world
this universe sort of came from is that
true i don't know is it true daniel do
you know i believe it is i believe it
started with uh with his own invented
language and then he created a world in
which that language would
exist and from there
middle earth came and then came
the actual stories that most people know
yeah and the illustrations that um
tolkien
did for middle earth are absolutely
beautiful of course
very famous middle earth map that you've
probably signed four thousand times
quite simple but also some of the best
design things
yeah obviously we were lucky enough to
work with
john howe and alan lee over the years
and they're incredible illustrators and
they've and they've done their own maps
at times but the simplicity of what
tolkien did in those maps just brilliant
little dragons here yeah just beautiful
so if you don't mind daniel would you
talk us through
you would approach uh either a real map
because i saw that you you do actually i
saw a really beautiful one of ireland
that you did
um or or a fictional one like your
dungeons and dragons how do you start
making a map
well the process is
mostly the same for either one
um
and it depends on if it's a commission
for a client or if it's just personal
work
for clients i usually work with drafts
so a rough sketch get feedback
then the next draft to flesh out the
details get feedback again
and then a final draft with all the
feedback worked into it for my personal
maps i usually just
start drawing and i
i see very interesting shapes all around
me yeah for example my first map that
started my world building campaign was
um
based on a stain that i found on a light
switch somewhere
stain that's brilliant
did you did you work out
what caused the stain oh it's probably
the the dirty tenants that lived in our
house before us
dirty tenants that's a great name for a
punk band
that's fantastic then the first album
could be tea toasting
so and and as billy had said
this kind of seemed to
begin with your
your interest in in the maps of of
tolkien what he'd drawn for lord the
rings so
just to just to go even further back
from from the um from your own map
building
when were you introduced to tolkien how
did how did that happen and when did you
first kind of
read the lord
well i
i first watched the movies
um
and i must have been about 10 years old
at the time i believe
and i got obsessed with them and i got
got the books and i started reading
those
and every time that a character was
mentioned at some place i went to the
map and looked it up
so i completely fell in love with that
map
but yeah it was through the movies that
i got introduced to uh to tolkien's work
i think i think a map is a great thing
to have on a wall and in a house i think
it like even seeing that one behind you
there it's it always brings you back to
it like you did when you were reading
the books
you go and you know i think a map you
always find yourself going back to it
and looking at coast or how would it get
from there to there i think it's a great
thing to have and it's brilliant
especially in tolkien it's brilliant to
plot the journey that let's say for the
exam for an example all of the
fellowship individually take yeah the
amount of miles yeah you cover in in
those trilogy of books is is
extraordinary not just frodo and sam who
obviously do a lot of traveling but you
know we all go to some crazy crazy
places yeah it was an adventure wasn't
it have you seen that map daniel and
billy because you're here in this
conversation too
have you seen that map
uh where you can scratch off places that
you've been to so it's a map of the
world
yeah it's and you can you can scratch
off and underneath it's uh it's a
different color so you you should be
basically done yeah a lot of it has
you've been all over the place my friend
adam who worked with us on wild things
very sweetly bought us all a copy of
that map and uh yeah we have covered
quite a few places very lucky very very
nice yeah i love maps so um if someone
and you do all sorts of maps from uh
real places as you say or from games or
from your own imagination and uh
actually that gives me an idea
don't listen to this storm okay
as you know dom likes league of legends
have you ever played league of legends
uh a long long time ago i did for a
short moment a couple rounds but i
i didn't really like it no oh you need
it back on you gotta get back out come
on play with us now if you you could do
a great map of uh league of legends and
i could give it a him for his next
birthday yeah as a gift
um
how how long would it take you to do a
commission
um it would be a couple weeks a couple
of weeks i'm sorry your trusty's not
till december yeah
and then i should have it done before
then oh that's great we should mention
very briefly because it's important
sometimes to give you a little shout out
yeah
for my 45th birthday which just went by
i went with billy to new york
took me out for dinner and he took me to
see a show and let me tell you i felt
romance that night i felt like a
wonderful princess i looked after you
that night i did we went to the theater
i said give us two of your best seats
the best they told us how much it was i
said what's your next next best seats
and that was still quite expensive so i
said what's your next next but that i
got those ones yeah and then i took him
out for dinner went for dinner before we
went to a show he bought me a glass of
wine on the walk home he said how are
you feeling i said i'm all right he said
are you peckish i said i could probably
eat something he said come on i'll buy
you a slice of new york pizza i didn't
put my hand in my pocket once the entire
night fantastic right daniel and next
year i'm going to get my map
league of legends so have a look and see
if you could do that and maybe i'll
write to you and see if that's something
that would be very cool because i really
do love your work i think it is
beautiful really beautiful and where are
you in the world where i am in the world
i'm in the netherlands and then
whereabouts in the netherlands uh near
amherst ford
or otherwise utrecht oh i don't utrecht
utrecht i think i know uh i think i know
that
from that is pretty much in the center
of the netherlands okay so i used to
live in germany as a kid and we would
often go over to the netherlands or
holland as we called it back then
um
to to go to like the markets and stuff
flower markets and fruit markets and
stuff there's a city called i'm
definitely going to get the
pronunciation wrong cockham
do you know that place
controversial
oh what's it
i guess
hey uh daniel as someone who comes from
the netherlands
why when is the appropriate time to call
it the netherlands and when would you
call it holland or is holland just an
old name that you don't call it anymore
no no actually it's um the netherlands
is the whole country
and you've got the province of north and
south holland
and it used to be one
province called holland
um and
way back in the day when the spanish
owned the netherlands
that was the richest part of the
netherlands so
they had
most say in everything that went on here
so people refer to it as holland because
that was the most important and most
powerful
uh part of the netherlands ah but that's
so that would be if i were referring to
your country as a whole it would be
incorrect to call it holland the
netherlands is the country holland is
like the richest district of yesterday
okay
and have you done a map of the
netherlands
i've done a
uh weird fantasy version of it oh cool
nice cool what would you oh william i
was just going to say i saw a really
lovely one you did of uh america usa but
it seemed like was that uh an old
way is that a fantasy version or was it
from the beginning of um the united
states as we know it
no it was um i think the map that you
mean was made for uh
a client and he wrote wrote a story
about
a man that was writing a fantasy story
and
the fantasy world and the real world
where that man
lived
had very much overlap in things that
were happening
and events that happened in one place
affected the other
so it was a map of
the united states as you know it
and ireland as we know it but it was
linked to that fantasy world that that
character was writing cool well as i say
i think it's great to have a map in the
house yeah i'll probably get in touch
daniel and people can see your work at
danielsmaps.com
dot com yes.com.com map or patreon
or patreon.com
danielsmaps okay cool easy i have one
last question for you daniel here it is
it's not that great a question oh think
of another one clutching up straws here
i was going to ask daniel over your
years of doing commissions was there one
particular map
that has stuck out in in your mind as
being
you know a very special job for you or
maybe an unusual job like if someone
were to say
tell me tell me one of the more
standout jobs that you've done what
would that be
well
there's two that come to mind really
that's one for a podcast that i didn't
actually know when i started working on
it
it was a dungeons and dragons podcast
and
as i was working on that map i started
listening to the podcast and
i became a huge fan of this show so
they were creating a setting book for
their campaign world
and i got to do all the maps for those
books they're working on the second book
right now and i'm the lead photographer
for it brilliant so
it's really great to be a part of that
and another one that's probably
my
biggest project that i've done so far is
um
for the entertainment weekly magazine
when they did the game of thrones
special for the season finale
uh i got to do the map for
um that magazine with all the routes
that the stark family members
went through throughout the whole
show brilliant that's fantastic i've got
a question tom and this might not be one
that you know daniel might be one that
you know i don't know i mean i hope so
when people started making maps
how did they do it
like there wasn't helicopters or
anything how did you make a map when you
couldn't look down at something like
how did you make it
it's a great it's a great question
i don't know the exact method but i i
know that um
they would just stand at certain points
on hills
yeah and draw a straight line between
those two and then
do that
dozens of dozens of time from times from
different places so like
guys
one would go a hill like
500 yards away and i would be on the
other hill you'd be the other guy on the
other hand would be happy to be that guy
and then we'd say look at that it goes
in
oh and then there's a big rock how high
are you i'm pretty high okay mark that
down
two wins in a big rock all right move to
the next and then i i would go to the
hill that he was on he'd go to the next
hill this could be a movie tom yeah it
could be the map makers me and you i i
get the feeling that you and i would
create a slightly surreal map i think it
would be perfect to the absolute inch
so that's what they did was it
so like a whole country the first guy
that did africa was two guys standing on
hills
well probably not two guys but i know
that uh the french king eventually
wanted a very accurate map of his
kingdom so that he knew how big it was
exactly yeah and there was this family
of photographers and they worked on that
map for several generations using
a technique like that i don't know the
exact technique how it works exactly but
it is something like that and they
worked on it for several generations
until the map was finally done wow well
if anyone knows the absolute story of
that french family of map makers yeah
let us know we'll put it on peeling the
onion yes and we'll talk about it next
week well we could talk to you all day
daniel the more we talk to you the more
questions we have but unfortunately we
probably have to move on right everybody
needs a map in our house and i would
recommend getting it from daniel get it
from daniel daniel we'll leave all your
information in our in our show notes but
it's wonderful chatting to you and good
luck with all of your your map making
ventures
yes thank you thank you for having me
and uh have a great day you too daniel
have a great one bye-bye thank you
daniel
valentine's day is just around the
corner and our sponsors at manscaped are
here for you with the best tools to get
your balls ready for the special
occasion
this valentine's day it's time to join
the four million men worldwide who trust
manscaped the leaders in below the waist
grooming with our exclusive offer go to
manscape.com and use the code onion for
20 off and free shipping
clean shaves are especially important on
valentine's day for your special someone
i'd like to propose making february 13th
a national holiday possibly national
shave day who's with me i think this is
one holiday that men and women can get
behind the holidays go by so quickly did
you remember to take care of your
package with the best tools for the job
the performance package 4.0 from
manscaped is just the very thing every
guy needs in their life to make each and
every day just a little more special the
number one product in this package is
the lawnmower 4.0 this electric trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
and get this the trimmer's advanced skin
save technology reduces cuts and nicks
around delicate areas it has a 4 000
led spotlight so you can shave anywhere
your heart desires did i mention that
it's waterproof too manscape created the
product for a night just like this so go
to manscape.com for our exclusive offer
of 20 off plus free shipping with the
code onion your special place will thank
you get 20 off and free shipping with
the code onion at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use the code onion your balls will
thank you manscaped this valentine's day
gaps in the diet shouldn't be ignored
over 97 of men aged 19 to 50 are not
getting enough vitamin d from their diet
and 95
are not getting their recommended daily
intake of key omega-3s rituals essential
for men 18 plus multivitamin was
formulated by exhaustive research to
help fill nutrient gaps in the diets of
men aged 18 plus it is formulated with
nutrients to help support brain health
bone health blood health and provide
antioxidant support
but ritual didn't stop there they
invested in a gold standard
university-led clinical trial to prove
the impact of essentials for men 18 plus
multivitamin
and let me tell you about the results
essential for men 18 plus were shown to
increase vitamin d levels by 43
and
3 dha levels by 41 in 12 weeks the
clinical study was published in leading
scientific journal frontiers in
nutrition ritual is committed to
third-party testing from usp and the
non-gmo project traceable and
vegan-friendly ingredients and always
clear communication no shady stuff very
important to have a multivitamin dom and
a good quality one like this
is very important especially for vitamin
d these days yeah you and i try and get
as much of our vitamins out of food but
sometimes you need a little extra help
and that's fine take a multivitamin
right now ritual is offering our
listeners 10
off your first three months visit
ritual.com
onion and turn healthy habits into a
ritual that's ten percent off at
ritual.com slash onion
yeah what a fantastic guest maps
now who do who's the first map
who was the first man who was the first
man
if you know the answer who made the
first map dom maybe thinks it's rome
no no i didn't say no i just said
but that was
in if you take the example of ancient
rome or egypt they would definitely need
maps for protection but the first maps i
mean
any group of people
trying to protect
their clan
would be making rudimentary maps you
know yeah i'm sure
the neanderthal man would be like
don't go over to the big rock because by
the big rock yeah there is the enemy and
people go where's the big rock and you
go yes give me this okay as a piece of
paper
we don't have pens we've always just
started to make plans
well that piece of chocolate we don't we
don't have fire yet
see the big boulder don't go over there
right got you we're ex good thing once a
few thousand years and it was rome at
least you knew if you got on a road
all roads lead to the road they do do
you don't really need a map you know
you're gonna get there i'm still
absolutely fascinated by the fact that
there are roads all over europe
built by the romans yeah that is just
crazy right isn't it crazy just think
about that you think no that can't be
right people are like no these
cobblestones were built by
romans and one day we'll get into the
london underground which is something i
don't believe exists ah if there's
anyone out there that's an expert on the
london underground building speak to
them he might be as fascinated about
that as deep space that's the one reason
i know we're living in a matrix
the london underground yeah it's the
oldest underground train system on the
planet and some guys went down there
with shovels
and built all that and put trains down
there and then you go on at baker street
and you change it waterloo that's crazy
no it didn't happen and how does it
criss-cross just perfectly yeah how do
they not miss waterloo by a couple of
feet they're like nah we're gonna have
to go to the next station
back there so two guys are doing with
shovels
give me a break i'll meet you in the
middle now
i don't buy it don't buy it either
oh emails and real mails fastest tigers
slow as snails billy do you want to read
this email out yeah you're ready yeah
it's david j
and david jay says i've been a fan of
both you both of you since the ladder
rings came out thanks to the podcast i
have tried iron brew
and i have to say it's probably
scotland's third best export after
connery and mr billy boyd fantastic i
would put iron brew above me actually
but that's very nice of you david thank
you i am proud to say i have marmite and
coleman's mustard on order and will
receive them in a few days
um jessica says
what is black when you buy it
red when you use it
and gray when you throw it away
now does she mean red as in
red or does she mean r-e-a-d well
exactly
a newspaper is red when you read it but
we've read it as red so
johnny no he's saying it's red our e.d
red
yes
so what is black black you buy it and
then so you buy it dom
you buy it it's not something that
you're born with or something that's
passed down to you it says here in black
and white
it's black when you buy it black when
you buy it but you want it to turn red
when you use it oh it's got to be red
when you use it but i tell you what dom
it's gray when you throw it away so it
loses its color and you throw it away
throw it away you don't so that means
you don't eat it
it's black
when you and
it's fragrant
this is a good one lips stick buy
something
[Music]
lipstick i was saying yeah but you don't
you wouldn't buy black lipstick that
often would you and it certainly doesn't
go gray
so black you but that's that's a crazy
conundrum you buy something that's black
but when you use it it goes red
right but it's a riddle so it's not
let's get out of the the the the the
literalness
literally yeah what's wrong with them
better here people yeah
we aren't peeling the onion and let's
start with gray when you throw it away
it's grayed on gray gray gray it goes
from red to gray red when you you
i'm emphasizing the use yeah
use it
i was going to say a t a television is
black when you buy it and then when you
turn on it's different colors but it's
definitely not red is it nice and you
wouldn't throw a tv perfectly red when
you use it well wait a minute all right
what no no i was thinking blood there
dom i was thinking blood oh you're
getting a bit gross there blood i think
we might need a a clue from johnny clue
give us a clue danny clue you want i i
can give you a hard quote
i can say this that it's
probably the most challenging and
the answer is kind of not that
satisfying
oh no
what you're saying it makes sense but
you're gonna go um it's a hard riddle
and it's not that and there's a is it
kind of surreal and it's
so it's quite
very it's very it's almost very literal
it's very so as something it's black
when you buy it let's just be casual
about that
it's black
right so i'll use it it's going to go
around right red when you grey when you
throw away so black when you buy it it's
right uh
i am
a diary
it's a diary
red when you use it but that would be
the other red yeah
and it's not ready could it be red
and it's gray
gray creek
[Music]
this actually is a good riddle to follow
the map maker okay follow the map makers
maps show
red
the show places it's black is it a
ticket it's [ __ ] like an airline
and it's great when you're buying is
there a ticket or something red when you
use it
gray when you throw it away blackmail
like a like a
good clue you would need for for dom's
definition of what a map serves you
might use a map to find
this thing
for what maps
find in a place
a map finds places right
that's what dom was saying or specific
things a specific thing like
cities as countries or something or
something agree with you
has anyone got this out there yet
because i'm finding which out of those
three johnny
the black when you buy it read when you
use it gray when you throw it away is
the most helpful in terms of getting it
i would say black and gray are probably
gonna be the ones that you go most like
the ah it's black when you buy it gray
when you throw it away i think we've
been stumped i think we have been
stumped here
let me give you another
um
think of uh
i'll put my glasses on because that
makes me more it does make easy
go
black
it's black when you buy it a ticket a
ticket
an aubergine an aubergine it might be
related to uh what you the the
map guys vehicles that are in the london
tunnels
trains it's a ticket it's a ticket it's
not a ticket black when you uh black
something through a train ships of power
oh steam engine
cool cool cool you about right when you
use a grim you throw away it is it's
cool it's cool when you buy it it's red
when it's in the fire and then it's the
ashes it's
have gotten no that was quite good
actually
that was quite good actually that of
jessica from saint louis you stopped us
we'll meet you at the fair and give you
a free t-shirt
jessica thanks and now it's time to eat
the world well i'll eat the world dump
billy and dom eat the world
well here we are you join myself here in
mr william boyd to my right hello
we are in uh
no expenses spared billion dollar meets
the world stage
getting ready to eat a mysterious dish
this week william it's over to you
dominic this one comes from cora hello
from the south eastern us and uh cora
says here in the south many people
love mayonnaise especially a brand
called dukes
we put me on everything but most
famously or perhaps infamously
on banana sandwiches
two pieces of white bread sliced bananas
and a generous dollop of mayo i think
it's an
abomination wow lovely ones yeah but i'd
like to see or hear what you both think
anyway thanks for the uh the podcast so
this came up last week again tom when
we're eating um peanut butter and uh
pickle with uh nick nick viall and uh
you thought we were going to be doing
this because you read this yeah so we
thought we'll do it this week yeah
because we've already mentioned it and
you think it sounds awful right
you i watched you make your own sandwich
and i made mine you slathered your bread
with mayonnaise covered i only put a
little bit of mayonnaise on mine nowhere
near as brave
as bill's cora comes from the south
eastern u.s but she doesn't say where
she's quite vague about where she does
she comes from where she lives she said
white bread we've done brown bread she
said sliced bananas we've sliced them
and she said a general doll a generous
dollop of duke's mayonnaise we've not
used juke's mayonnaise have we because
we couldn't source it no there's some
more blue but other than that we've got
an absolutely perfect tom absolutely
says
dale earnhardt jr who i believe is a is
a nascar driver is that right yes johnny
clues is nodding uh dale earnhardt jr
once tweeted that banana mayonnaise on
bread is one of his favorite snacks gq
magazine what does gq stand for
don't know gentleman's quarterly is it
real yeah wonderful gentleman's
quarterly magazine polled our readers
don't know how our readers are and out
of 35 000 votes an unbelievable 9
actually described that sandwich as
delicious well i mean
that's not very high is it nine percent
of 35 000 no it's not it's as really low
yeah that's not an unbelievable that is
terrible gordon ramsay on the sandwich
he says that would give me
a not too pleasant
gastro internet in intestinal
gastrointestinal situation for three
weeks throw it away and start again i
would not eat an effin banana and
mayonnaise no
whatever muppet put those two together
needs to clean their core
dale jr needs to call me that's what
gordon ramsay said about this sandwich
so dale earl earnhardt jr yes gordon
ramsay no
we were at one point obsessed with
gordon ramsay we would watch him a lot
at your house yeah he was good and we
noticed a lot of things jordan ramsay
does this a lot which is very
presidential you see a lot of leaders
around the world do this she goes that
[ __ ] chicken is raw
top more dressing on the salad it's raw
michael it's raw michael god all right
should we have a bye i'm not looking
forward to this here we go make sure you
get banana and mayo are you ready let's
do it okay
i mean i'm not even a massive banana
sandwich fan i like it with nutella i
love banana sandwiches get it all over
your face
i made sure i got a lot of it
um
i hope banana sandwiches i don't like
that really i met a guy i'm not a guy
once
i was buying a car
it was a nissan
and the guy i bought it from at the at
the place the nissan place had a banana
sandwich
every day of his life
for 35 years well i mean banana's very
good for you full of uh potassiums you
had told me the other day they're a
natural antidepressant is that right yes
yeah yeah so they're very good for you
you see a lot of um
athletes specifically tennis players in
between their little break from one set
to the other or one game today
very quickly eating a banana because
it's great for energy as and the more
yellow it is the more slow energy you
get and the more black it is boom wow
because the sugar's ready to go i'm not
a massive fan of bananas i love all
fruit and i'm okay with bananas but
they're not at the top of my list i
would put them probably down in in the
in the lower 50s of my fruit
you liking that i'm loving it i mean you
it's
you're still covered in mayonnaise i
would say
you look like the joker a little bit you
know when the joke had
his mouth like you want to know how i
got the scars
i'll have another bite i'm not crazy
about it it's
you've got the sugar from the banana and
the salt from the mayonnaise the
mayonnaise feels a little bit i think
because of the mayonnaise that johnny
close has got is
it tastes a bit like one you'd have with
a shrimp cocktail
oh
i got a strange toaster
it wasn't invented by dale earnhardt jr
says johnny clues it wasn't no it turns
out that the banana and mayonnaise
sandwich is a southern delicacy with a
storied history in 2014
nationals bullpen coach matthew lacroix
maybe
even credited credited it with the
team's
10 game winning streak what team
what is it the team that he managed
nice one john i wonder what sport
baseball i would say the banana and
mayonnaise sandwich gets at least enough
fans to have a facebook page with 1 200
likes so there's 1 200 people at you i
mean you're halfway through it why
doesn't everybody watch is this go onto
the facebook page banana me or simon
juice and double it at least
yeah i mean
dom
yeah i really like it honestly you'd be
surprised by how much mayo you got
around your face wipe your face now and
see because you'll be you'll be amazed
there's a lot
that's quite greasy now there's a lot
cleaner as a whistle now remember when
we um when we did load the rings and we
had to put on
uh
suntan lotion every morning because they
got angry if we ever get sunburned
remember
and you would always give me a hard time
in the morning because i haven't rubbed
that in there yeah yeah you would you
would study me you and the car
you seem to pride yourself on the thing
of like you put it on and then you go
slap slap slap slap and i'd always go
you've got a smear there
because i thought you're going to get a
suntan and then you're going to have
massive little streaks across your face
where it didn't hit now back to the
banana mayonnaise sandwich right
obviously we know that there are great
combinations of flavors out there that
kind of
come oh excuse me contradict each other
don't they do you mean yeah sweet and
spicy and
nice
well you know sour and
sweet
which i think is something yeah things
that yeah it feels like they shouldn't
go together they just pose but here's
the thing tom like the one that we had
last week with the uh peanut butter and
pickle which i quite liked it came from
the great depression is that right yeah
if you dig a little deeper the sandwich
is linked to the peanut butter and
mayonnaise sandwich really that sounds
awful mm-hmm we'll try that as well the
two ingredients in particular according
to garden and gun were staples during
the great depression and the following
years 30s up to the 60s apparently
mayonnaise was added to smoothing out
the peanut butter and then also serving
as a calorie rich meal
and somewhere along the way they opted
for bananas instead of peanut butter
well you and i both like a banana
sandwich i've had banana sandwiches over
the years with uh chocolate hazelnut
spread which is fantastic
that's a great uh combination i've had
banana sandwiches with jam yup
i'm not too sure about them i'm gonna
have one more you're almost halfway
through i think i like that one
bites i'm not crazy about it
no
i like it there's something about it i
quite like would you say that you like
that more than last week's uh peanut
butter and pickle yeah sandwich really
yeah i do um so i need to remember the
scores i gave now because yeah yeah if i
give better scores to the one last week
yeah
well let's let's do score let's score it
so um
taste
dom i'm going to give her a 9.4 wow you
genuinely do like it it's not like a
gimmick no i actually really i would do
that again i'm confident in saying that
i probably would never eat that again by
choice wow um i'm gonna give it a two
i didn't like it well
how does it look to you well it's a
banana mayonnaise sandwich isn't it i
mean that looks revolting actually
yeah it doesn't look good when you open
that up show that to the
camera there i see that
it's not it's not very attractive
um
i'll give it a i'll give it a four
for
looks aesthetics
don't uh yeah it doesn't look great i
mean yeah i'm go i'll give her a five
okay no usefulness usefulness if you
were in the great depression listen
beggars can't be chooses as can they see
and at that point obviously everyone's
struggling with a little bit of money
yeah calories we need calories calories
you need something to feed your kids you
know we're trying to make we're trying
to make
maps of this this new country and and
also things that last you know
mayonnaise you can put on a
on a
cupboard and it'll stay good for a while
i would assume right now
bananas don't now they go fast i hate
that yeah
not as fast as that
yeah
they're
well at least with a banana you see it
yeah changing you go okay i need a
couple of days for that but a pear the
night before you think now there's a few
days on that you wake up the next
morning done oh yeah you can eat every
bit of up here is that right you told me
that i think i'm not sure if that was me
actually wasn't it no my brother used to
i don't know if he does it anymore but
my brother used to eat every bit of an
apple
that's not good because the seeds are
actually poisonous is that right yeah
tell them not to do that never put an
apple on a like one of those machines
not the whole apple not the seeds
because see if you break the seed down
that's poison
is that right uh
anyway um
where are we at oh usefulness
well i always think with something like
this can you bring it
on a on a journey on on a car journey on
a trip
you go into the cinema something like
that on a road trip you could definitely
bring banana and mayonnaise sandwiches
on a road trip there's no problem with
that
is that how you equate that's how i
equate usefulness my usefulness is like
if it's all i had in the house what
could i do with it is it easy and you've
normally got a banana and you've
normally got mayonnaise bread so i'm
like i can find it but is there anything
else i can do with it no
i bet elvis used to like these
sandwiches no no
what did you like peanut butter fried
peanut butter and and jelly sandwiches
as they say
travel or a certain place and get them
wouldn't they and i think sometimes he
would put a few slices of bacon in there
he liked his calories
died on the toilet is that true though
the king died on the toilet
um
dom i can only give that a four for
usefulness to be honest
i think i'll give it a four two
not a forty-two a four
a four guys
get in touch with us if you want us to
eat the world we enjoy the slightly
stranger ones even though i didn't
necessarily like the taste of that i do
like trying new things you do so thank
you very much cora that was love i would
have that again cora my friend here on
my left dominic monahan would not no
hey tom that was fun once it wasn't that
a great episode man daniel
we did maps we did eat the world
we did a riddle that stumped us send us
in your riddles if you think they can
stomp us the friendship bunny at
castmedia.com also there's still merch
around and available that's uh the
friendship
onionpodcast.com that's where you get
the t-shirts and hoodies and all that
hey we'll see you all next week don't
forget to rate
subscribe
review review that's the other one tom
we love hearing from you guys and we
will see you
next week on the friendship onion
doodles
[Music]
all through the night you're shining
bright i'm your host the baby you're my
pearl
[Music]